Phó thu dưới chính phủ hòa đất phóc đã khi công điện số 1 thay tư ngày 30,5%
mấy làm của thu dưới chính phủ người các bộ ngành địa phương về tiếp thuốc đầy thêm
toàn không dục tiên mặt. Công địa nưu gió vừa qua hoàn động thêm toàn măng tiên
mặt có dấu hiệu gia tăng, anh vẫn không tốt đến nền kinh tế, người làm phi quần lực, có thể bị
lợi dục để chốn thế, dự tin và các khoản động vi vạc pháp lật. Để tiếp tục phát triển
thêm toàn không dùng tiên mặt theo đúng các lực tiêu dải pháp đại đầy ra phó thu dưới
thêm yêu cầu các bộ của các khoản ngặng bộ của quan thuộc chính phủ của y bán như giành các tình
thành phố trực thục trung ngương theo chức năng vụ và thầm quyền được giao, khẩn trường, thực hiện nay
các giải phó thu dưới thêm toàn không dùng tiên mặt. Tăng cường có tất chi đã ổ thương giận tuyên
sự liên nghiêm các hành đi v vạc pháp lật. Bộ tài chính được giao tăng cường thêm cha kiểm tra
việc tôn thủ quy định về hóa đơn, chứng tư, ngăn hàng nhé lước khẩn trường phát triển hạ tần công nghệ
bảo đam, thành toàn không dục tiên mặt thông xuất, an toàn đáp ứng như cầu của miếng dân và dân nghiệp chính phủ khẳng liệt.
Đây là dài pháp quan trọng giúp tiếp kiểm chế vị, chống thất thu thui thủy và thúc đầy trên được số quốc gia.